let's go to the phone 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
caller from the 5 4 1 area code go right
ahead
what's on your mind today 5 4 1 can you
hear me oh hi there you are sorry yes I
live in the 7 1 4 area code now sorry my
phone is 5 4 1
oh no problem oh yes I have a question
with the intercepts reporting on the
Trump administration and dealings in the
Middle East countries within Israel why
is the mainstream media continuously
pushing the Russia scandal how are the
two things related I'm not sure I know
so a scandal seems to be more about the
Middle East countries Saudi Arabia and
Israel more so than Russia like for
example what's your scan well yeah let's
make sure we run the same page what's
the scandal with Saudi Arabia for
example the arms sales yeah ok and then
what's the scandal with Israel also arms
sales and expanding for moving the
building to Jerusalem gosh darn it what
the Empire moving the embassy to
Jerusalem yes yes ok between the embassy
did at Jerusalem yeah well I mean so
let's see let's take let's break it down
into its component parts arms sales to
Saudi Arabia and Israel whether you're
for them or against them it has nothing
to do with Trump specifically right I
mean the that's been going on
administration after administration
administration it doesn't represent any
particular change Trump did escalate the
arms sales to Saudi Arabia but like
that's not anything that Trump's
campaign did that might have broken
campaign finance laws or that could
include you know witness tampering or
the criminality that Muller is
investigating so I think that you're
right that we should of course be
questioning all proliferation of arms
around the world but I just don't
understand the connection to the the
Russia thing that you're bringing up
okay
I will I'll come back to you with a
better question on another date okay all
right sounds good well I did the best I
could with the question I got it i hope
i hope it was something thank you
appreciate it